[Music]
in snitch app news
submitted by freedom fries China is
launching an app that tells you if you
are within 500 yards of someone in debt
one that's some Ray Bradbury [ __ ] right
no they're like get away from me you owe
money yeah Wow
why is that mattered so they are trying
to encourage these people to send them
to report them to report them to report
them yeah aren't you already reported
Finn if you're on the app yeah um so
they encourage these people so let's say
you have is that right yeah yeah it
gives you a notification like oh this
person near you is in debt so then they
want me to go up to that person if they
look like they're capable of repaying
and just be like hey loser you know you
need to pay your debt okay so they're
letting citizens be like the debt
collectors yeah much they're being your
little aunties and also [ __ ] Asian
nosy yeah you know I mean that says no
the Asian as you can get that happens at
Korean churches and [ __ ] Asian
churches all the time look you know you
know they're going through like black
mirror kind of [ __ ] right now where
we've got that people ratings - yeah
yeah yeah so if you did somebody wrong
or like you cheated somebody or whatever
you could rape them and they everybody
has already ultra view on them yeah
they're saying that the reason why
they're doing is for an alternatives so
it's an alternative system to assess
whether people can pay off the loans
rent houses or even since it's like
their credit score yeah because not a
lot of people have access to traditional
banks is what they say but people are
fallible like someone can lie about you
you cannot like a restaurant then give
it one star even though it just deserves
like yeah I'm ticked down and a gang of
twenty people can come up and just rate
all of like rate you that yeah they are
like do this for us so we're gonna leave
some bad reviews you're not a nice
person you wouldn't do this for us
yeah it's just a very flawed system
because it's based on you thinking that
every humans gonna be honest yeah and
that's not going to happen well and your
own you you are your own my
morale marker yeah it depends on how
good you are and how you view other
people shipping huh I think they wanted
a throwaway Confucius and and all the
other Buddhism and all that stuff and
become communist with no culture or
ideals so now they that's what they're
dealing with is like there was a system
and then they they they burned all those
books that's so weird because even that
always played back to like filial piety
I guess like but you know working for
the family working toward society
structure so it seemed like it's always
a good idea to like have a religious or
like social belief system that ties back
into your government if you want to they
already had that well you know when they
had the Cultural Revolution is like they
wanted they consider all that stuff old
world so they burned all that stuff and
and so there's a there's a huge cultural
separation or disconnect from mainland
Chinese and Chinese Americans or Chinese
Australians or whatever they don't they
don't see eye to eye because of the
people that stayed there with communist
education and all that stuff
they weren't encouraged to push on the
culture mmm yeah
in that sense so I mean because of that
like I mean we have cultural differences
between us and like new mainland Chinese
like we don't get them we just don't
it's like what is what are you doing
like what's the problem if I put
somebody else's I mean just crazy it's
just crazy like the problem I'm not in
there I'm a [ __ ] you know out all right
the one in bit [ __ ] low credit score
but you mean even your dad said right
like when cuz he escaped Communist China
and when he goes you were like what he's
like that's not the same China that I
knew yeah and and I think it's exactly
that like they threw away all those
codes of what made that culture of
culture that might my parents so they're
like both different kinds of Chinese my
mom's Taiwanese and my dad's from China
so he grew up in communist China or they
threw like all the Confucian estoy deals
away so when they had me they were
disgusting so my dad speaks Cantonese
my mom speaks Mandarin and then they're
discussing like which what should be the
main language at home because we're both
learning each other's language sure and
they decided to go with Mandarin because
at least Taiwan still held on to the old
Confucianist cultures and so it's like a
sophisticated system versus my dad's
like I'm cultureless so like he's like
I'm pretty much like the savage
barbarian with no culture so like if we
if he at least can learn your language
then we'll learn your ideals like how to
bow to people like elders eat first like
there's this entire world that's already
constructed what's ironic all those
ideals I'm aware of all of it so now you
just have shame I built that dad anytime
I want it's just not - I don't know
about that I've never seen somebody cut
a birthday cake with their hands unless
they were [ __ ] 2 years old they're
talking about or if it grabs your pasta
with his bare hands I know dude this is
like you want some of my banana that's
and that hurts hurts to watch see tastes
better that way
no it does not did you end up like
mission a lot of the middle no you just
pinched the the bottom end that's what
he does dude when he has to pee that's
what he does he's [ __ ] banana like this
he goes oh one t-shirt banana and you
sticks it right in the middle like this
and goes oh and he gives it back to you
what is dirtiest hands ever it's like
where were you in sand no it's so gritty
all right salt back to this debt
collector yeah this is what it looks
like
give me back my money Oh like a radar
five hundred yards it's a submarine and
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] don't these people
actually movie I know don't these people
with the app though have better [ __ ] to
worry about no they don't not if you're
Asian can I talk [ __ ] to today oh five
people is that all that app does it just
looks for people with bad day
yeah there's no reward yeah do they get
like points cuz like I talked to this
guy and I told him bad boy they don't
mention that got him like work this into
a mobile game like i play the final
fantasy 1 and i'm like if that gave me
in game currency I would absolutely rat
on my friends because you know what you
know be cool if this was like a peer to
peer lending thing mmm and then like you
use everyone that's on this app you lend
each other money and then you know that
sounds sketchy already so you already
can't repay their debt no no you use the
same one you say we all download this
app right we all download this app and
then we lend each other money and then
let's say like I don't pay you back
but then only you know that but now
everybody on the app knows my my
borrowing history but that's what that's
what it is I don't want anybody all the
same thing no I was wondering if they do
that where they actually lend money on
the app because they'll be pretty clear
that this is a like the Chinese
authorities have developed this app to
tell people other citizens of people
that are nearby their angers you know be
cool shame them to either I mean I'd be
does that mean I think it's why I mean
that pedophiles are not as like they're
not afraid of pedophiles they're afraid
of people that are in debt a
neighborhood watch like yeah because
they have this in the states if your
neighbors like a sex offender or
whatever it's like all these dots right
by the way you know it's cool is
Monterey Park is clear of a lot of sex
offenders yeah yeah it's like all this
[ __ ] red and then you just see
Monterey Park but we're never leaving
yeah but if you have an app this is
[ __ ] car accidents it's just
everything else is [ __ ] big
so they all got their [ __ ] caveats
that's clean I rather be around people
who have a tax and get in car accidents
than freaking sex sexual that's true
predators know Matt Picht you're
poisoned did ya is the app mandatory
because if the if like the NSA was like
we've got a new app you're down on it be
like you don't you can stop there's
people though that are so self-righteous
that they know the right way and
everyone else needs to be [ __ ] doing
the way this stuff the way that they do
it that they can't wait there likes
elevating to the start to telling us
some people are just [ __ ] [ __ ]
they just want to do dude when uh when I
was traveling to Houston there was a
[ __ ] lady who the the flight
attendant told her lady you can't put
your bag if you're in the front seat you
can't put your bag under the seat you
have to put it in the overhead bin and
she told her and then she comes up and
she goes ma'am make sure that you put
your thing into over a pen she goes what
what's the problem like what enough but
like people just wanted they're just so
fighter so they just like up they feel
like they have the right to do whatever
they want yeah and I [ __ ] hate that
and some people they always want they
think that everything is a personal
attack yeah so she's just trying to lay
out a policy and she's like [ __ ] with me
it's like what the [ __ ] yeah and then
and then her boyfriend was being an
[ __ ] too cuz you know she was like
from Southwest and she's doing like
jokes and stuff and he's like Oh real
funny real funny oh my god you finally
garbage human they you know like for me
like I was on the other side I don't
think I really would have said anything
but it was just kind of like other
people were kind of like staring at them
like come on like it's not being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] but it's like what the
[ __ ] are you doing what that do for you
jackass you know I was at the San
Antonio Airport and this is like one
time when there was a hall monitor that
I was like oh [ __ ] yeah this is dumb but
like there was these like college kids
or whatever but they were eating and
they're making a [ __ ] mess like all
over like trash on the floor crumbled up
like food all this [ __ ] right and in
this big-ass bald white dude right he
was just sitting there you staring at
him and he's like where's your manners
boy I was like oh [ __ ]
and then he's like I will [ __ ] you up
she's scared the [ __ ] daylights out
of those kids they're like oh [ __ ]
and they started cleaning up he's like
and he got up and he came back and he
goes if I [ __ ] see some trash I swear
to god oh [ __ ] you up like you say
something like those lights and I was
just like wow that is that is some good
[ __ ] my god that that's dope that's the
presence of a lion dude yeah I said the
same thing they would've threw [ __ ]
pie in my face dude
where's your manners children oooh my
face is just slides right down I don't
know there was like a fatherly added to
it too cuz he looked like a coach of
some sort yeah Letta core something oh I
don't got that yeah and I was just like
damn and I was like that's dope man we
were at the UFC where we're at and then
there's like this a bunch of dudes that
came in front of us and so I kind of
blocked the view and then all's I fight
in my mind on my god damn it you just
like it low or whatever but the guy that
was sitting to the diagonal me I was
like can you guys get any taller oh yeah
it was finally all his remarks we're
always extremely sarcastic so it made
you laugh but also let you know you
[ __ ] up yeah see people are like six
eight that's pretty funny I'm I'm like a
bad combination of like I'm too polite
so it makes you definitely not want to
do the thing I'm just like hey guys I'm
so sorry to like be that guy and like
bug you but like if it's not to trouble
too much trouble at all do you brother
it's kind of okay alright thank you you
didn't know them do that
that's [ __ ] tight dude you've got
them hey guys so um have you guys heard
of Jehovah Witnesses I think they're
just like no work you know I just want
to talk to you about the gospel please
that was suck though I don't know how to
confront in the middle I'm like yous
like I'm just I'm really polite cuz I
don't like it when people tell me what
to do either sure it's like I just don't
want to make it their thing but if they
take the kindness for weakness then I
immediately snap yeah yeah what the hell
[ __ ] yo [ __ ] back
[Music]